pendant une journée ou une erreur de
lieu de la civilisation or de
l'urbanisation voit juste des arbres la
magnificience de la forêt les animaux
qu'on peut croiser son à la chance on
est à cheval avec les chiens il ya quand
même quelque chose qui redonne à l'homme
ses instances et ses origines ses bas je
m'appelle avis j'ai 17 ans je suis
lycéenne en terminale et du coup je
chasse depuis que je suis petit
tous les soirs donc en rentrant du bus
est sûre je cherchais mes cheveux en
pâture et je monte à cheval et surtout
cette petite du mans je monte en club
depuis que j'ai 6 ans je travaille mon
cheval comme un cheval de sport mais ces
chevaux avant tout c'est des chevaux de
chasse et donc nous on a la pleine en
jeu derrière chez nous donc on galope
beaucoup ils peuvent endurer quatre cinq
heures de chasse sans problème parce
qu'ils sont très bien entraînés par les
airs dont l'un est en pleine forme pour
attaquer même si on dirait pascal dans
un peu alors elle voulait me vendre pour
attaquer cette nouvelle saison qui a
déjà commencé d'ailleurs on fait quand
on va à la chasse on se replonge pendant
une journée où on y re or de lieux de la
civilisation or de l'urbanisation on
voit juste des arbres la magnificience
de la forêt les animaux qu'on peut
croiser ce on a la chance on est à
cheval avec les chiens il ya quand même
quelque chose qui redonne à l'homme ses
instances et ses origines c'est avant
tout les joints de gaza comment soutenir
les chiens sombre
si tu choisis pour la chaise présent
quand le chien qui chasse par la chasse
et on les monte dans le camion après on
se retrouve tous au rendez vous ici avec
tous les chevaux les safer et gien elle
a entendu des chiens sales gueules
bientôt partir c'est quand même une
espèce d' aventure en une journée ou
espèces des têtes truc est quand même
c'est vrai que galoper dans belle forêt
picarde derrière des chiens qui chassent
en serre seraient c'est oui c'est hyper
excitant c'est josiane l'adrénaline même
les chevaux sont excités on voit les
choix
[Musique]
les chiens ont attaqué ils ont trouvé le
cerf est tout beau il l'on suit est donc
là je sais les parties un moment plein
est venu d'en sauver les chiens essaye
de le leur avant nous c'est quand même
les chiens qui chasse donc c'est quand
même un rapport animal animal qui est
c'est un animal contrat n'est elle-même
ici nous on est là pour les nerfs sont
là pour encadrer les chiens c'est quand
même quelque chose
de très égalitaire quand même dans la le
rapport entre le cerf et les animaux
même nous on est à cheval
et comme je le dis on comprend pourront
presque pas toutes les chasses là on est
en plein défaut c'est à dire que l'on a
perdu la trace du cerf le cerf a joué de
ses multiples ruse pour nous perdre et
donc les chiens essayer de retrouver la
voix mais on sait pas où aller et la
voix c'est la trace que le serbe fait
par son odeur et du coup on ne cherche
oui je les ai vus 310 corps avec la avec
les bois noir où il est reconnaissable
et ça empire trice welt donc il est très
rapide et et henry lee a l'air d'être en
pleine forme
la curie pour moi c'est quand même un
moment de profond respect même si
l'animal est mort tué l'animal on le
sonn on l'applaudît où les chiens sur la
attendre devant lui c'est le lot de tous
les jours vous tous la mort existe la
souffrance existe nous on veut pas ça
pour le cerf on veut on veut une belle
une belle mort c'est pour ça qu'on le
sait être ou s'il est possible de servir
le gracie mais on ne laissera jamais
après je vous et vous voir du sang
l'animal la mort gisant c'est pas
forcément un moment de plaisir pour moi
un plaisir intense
non non pas c'est l'aboutissement de la
chasse oui on a sonné la ruse et les
donjons des rentrées on investit 7
heures à cheval bon au moins troisième
on applique le marché où s'arrêter elle
a fait que brut et meiwey on a fait
sauter ipad g20 peuvent être liés mais
c'était une bonne chose malgré tout
alors là on n'a pas eu ses bas c'est lui
qui a gagné
là encore aujourd'hui
nous a montré qu'il est plus rusé que
les chiens il ya des icônes et la forêt
parker ici comment s'en sortir hélas ces
sept ans bossert et où il nous a montré
que c'était lui le maître des forêts
[Musique]